after seven years of development Porsche
has launched a second totally revamped
generation of the Panamera the new
entry-level engine has less capacity
than its predecessor but more power and
the new Panamera comes with an
eight-year dual clutch transmission
artistic clothes needs fit says it's a
real treat to drive this Porsche
Panamera and feel it glide along you can
enjoy the cars new entertainment system
it's comfy suspension and engine
characteristics the fab Xin still young
oddly comfortable 5x and Shalom who
taught in moto characteristic Kinnison
342 kilowatts of power carry the 2 ton
beast from 0 to 100 km/h in just 4.2
seconds it may not sound like an average
entry-level car but in this case it is
the panamera 4s now uses one liter less
than its predecessor per hundred
kilometers
I've lots of do the noise mom says this
2.9 v6 twin-turbo engine runs very
smoothly and the engine doesn't suffer
from turbo lag because it's made with a
whole new technology the Panamera can do
up to 290 kilometers per hour and run
smoothly on Zeb star by holding finished
item come kinda on the high it now as a
compliment many rejected the first
generation Panamera for somewhat ugly
rear design the new model has massively
improved on this the trunk in the
redesigned rear has a volume of 500
litres without having to fold down the
rear seats this new Panamera comes with
a new steering concept in the back and
in the cockpit as well
edly for our car Chester says he's glad
the buttons on the middle console have
been scrapped now it has a touchscreen
and there's also this multi-purpose 12.3
inch display Alice Mahan con closes you
can even hook up Portia connect or Apple
connect the round digital instruments
are appealing as well only the
tachometer remains an analog device a
Porsche Panamera combines both comfort
and sportiness one way it can do this is
the optional adaptive air suspension
available for just over 2,000 euros in
Germany
boss admin clerk law says now drive
modes are changed using this little dial
the suspension can be set to normal
sport or even Sport Plus sport plus
makes everything a little stiffer and
racier and it's even possible to select
your very own settings and decency avah
clothes takes the Panamera up a winding
Mountain Road that's been blocked off
for test driving he's driving in Sport
Plus mode to test the optional rear axle
steering and torque vectoring a computer
calculates the car's condition in real
time and then adjust all systems to the
situation for an optimal driving
experience
so yeah it's Klaus speeds up the
mountain he's disabled the Porsche
Stability management but the car still
remains very stable while accelerating
touch him by my husband Sean Tehan it
says altas if he gets super big the rear
swerves a little but this new panamera
4s comes with four wheel drive enhancing
stability the class warns that only
expert drivers should disable the
Porsche Stability management fifties nua
I in Pokemon Porsches engineers have
made the new Panamera even sporty-er the
optional rear axle steering makes it
more maneuverable this system is already
in Porsches 911
lavenda me [ __ ] Klaus is verdict the
Panamera is a real racer it's more
advanced than the previous generation
and looks better to the entry-level
model starts at one hundred thirteen
thousand euros Klaus knows that's a
hefty price but thinks that's a lot of
bang for your buck nikada vena cava mom
become dull and he got to me